Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Emma Gon
Si extraes toda el agua de tu cerebro
y fraccionas su contenido
en sus constituyentes nutricionales,
¿cómo luciría?
La mayor parte del peso de tu cerebro
deshidratado provendrían de las grasas,
también conocidos como lípidos.
En el resto de la masa cerebral,
encontrarías proteínas y aminoácidos,
trazas de micronutrientes
y glucosa.
El cerebro es, por supuesto, más que
la suma de sus partes nutricionales,
pero cada componente tiene
un claro impacto en el funcionamiento,
desarrollo,
estado anímico,
y energía.
La apatía después del almuerzo,
o el estado de alerta de tarde-noche
que puedes sentir, bueno,
podrían ser simplemente los efectos
de los alimentos en tu cerebro.
De las grasas en el cerebro,
las superestrellas son las omegas 3 y 6.
Estos ácidos grasos esenciales,
que se han relacionado con la prevención
de condiciones degenerativas del cerebro,
deben provenir de nuestra dieta.
Así, el consumo
de alimentos ricos en omega,
como frutos secos,
semillas,
y las grasas de pescados,
son cruciales para crear y mantener
las membranas celulares.
Y mientras omegas son
grasas buenas para el cerebro,
el consumo de largo plazo otras grasas,
como las grasas trans y saturadas,
puede poner en peligro
la salud del cerebro.
De otra parte,
las proteínas y aminoácidos,
los ladrillos nutrientes
del crecimiento y desarrollo,
manipulan la forma en que
nos sentimos y comportamos.
Los aminoácidos contienen
los precursores de los neurotransmisores,
los mensajeros químicos que llevan
señales entre las neuronas,
que afectan cosas como el estado de ánimo,
sueño,
atención,
y el peso.
Pueden ser la razón de que sientas
calma luego de un gran plato de pasta,
o más alerta después
de una comida rica en proteínas.
Las combinaciones complejas
de compuestos en los alimentos
pueden estimular las células del cerebro a
liberar noradrenalina que altera el humor,
dopamina,
y serotonina.
Pero llegar a las células
del cerebro es complicado,
y los aminoácidos tienen que
competir por el acceso limitado.
Una dieta con una gama de alimentos ayuda
a mantener una combinación equilibrada
de mensajeros cerebrales,
y evita que tu estado de ánimo
se incline en una dirección u otra.
Como los otros órganos de nuestro cuerpo,
nuestro cerebro se beneficia de
un abasto constante de micronutrientes.
Los antioxidantes en las frutas
y verduras apoyan al cerebro
en su lucha contra los radicales libres
que destruyen neuronas,
lo que permite a tu cerebro a trabajar
bien por un período de tiempo más largo.
Y sin micronutrientes poderosos,
como la B6 vitaminas,
B12,
y el ácido fólico,
nuestros cerebros serían susceptibles a
la enfermedad cerebral y deterioro mental.
Trazas de los minerales hierro,
cobre,
zinc,
y sodio
son también esenciales
para la salud del cerebro
y el desarrollo cognitivo temprano.
Para que el cerebro transforme
y sintetice de manera eficiente
estos nutrientes valiosos,
necesita combustible, y mucho de él.
Aunque el cerebro humano solo es cerca
del 2 % de nuestro peso corporal,
utiliza hasta un 20 % de
nuestros recursos energéticos.
La mayor parte de esta energía
proviene de los carbohidratos
que nuestro cuerpo digiere en
glucosa o azúcar en la sangre.
Los lóbulos frontales son tan sensibles
a las caídas en la glucosa, de hecho,
que un cambio en la función mental
es una de las señales primarias
de la deficiencia de nutrientes.
Suponiendo que recibimos
glucosa con regularidad,
¿cómo afecta a nuestro cerebro
el tipo específico de
carbohidratos que comemos?
Los carbohidratos
se presentan en tres formas:
almidón,
azúcar
y fibra.
Aunque que en la mayoría
de las etiquetas de nutrición,
se agrupa al total de hidratos de carbono,
la proporción de azúcar
y los subgrupos de fibra en el total
afecta la forma en que
el cuerpo y el cerebro responden.
Alimentos con alto contenido glucémico,
como el pan blanco,
causan una liberación rápida
de la glucosa en la sangre,
y luego viene una caída.
El azúcar en la sangre cae, y con ella,
nuestra capacidad de atención y ánimo.
Por otro lado, la avena, granos y legumbres
tienen la liberación de glucosa más lenta,
que permiten un nivel
más constante de atención.
Para mantener el poder cerebral,
opta por una dieta variada de alimentos
ricos en nutrientes es fundamental.
Cuando se trata de lo
que muerdes, masticas y tragas,
tus decisiones tienen
un efecto directo y de larga duración
en el órgano más poderoso en tu cuerpo.